I knew that there had been kind of an
embedded special
FBI team that was you know communicating
regularly with with Twitter shaping some
of their content decisions kind of
nudging them towards censorship of
various accounts I just didn't
understand the volume
[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I'm enjoined in London
by Lee Fang Lee is an independent
journalist who until March 2023 was at
the American left-wing Media Group the
intercept and since gone independent but
was also one of the leading journalists
on the Twitter files at the end of 2022
part of the team that went in with
Michael schellenberger Barry Weiss and
Matt taibi into Twitter HQ upon Elon
musk's invitation but also one of the
very few
journalists to report on antifa
certainly maybe the only left-wing
journalist to report on and if I can
call you left wing but anyway there's
much to get into Lee thank you for
joining me today Winston thanks for
having me pleasure to be here
um so you're in London for the um the
event with Michael shannenberger and
Matt Tybee the censorship industrial
complex exposed which I'm look forward
to getting into because you've been a
big part of exposing that and
um that's not least with your Twitter
files coverage but
one of the the things that's striking
about reading your story is the
sensoriousness within journalism and if
I can if I can start if you don't mind
which I I think might be mildly
traumatic or maybe more maybe not the um
incident from the 2nd of June 2020 the
height of the BLM
movement you're in Oakland
reporting capturing a video interviews
with protesters and others and you
capture this interview for black man
called Max who
says why does a black life matter only
when a white man takes it and he had
critiques of the BLM movement despite
supporting it you published that video
and and
your world sort of seemed to cave in can
you tell us about that experience yeah
you know it's hard to kind of place
yourself in that moment because that
moment is very unique that was perhaps
the height of racial anger in the United
States at least since the 60s you know
and
in that moment it was chaotic coming out
of lockdowns
um you know this was Trump presidency
um this was only a few days after the
first initial riots in Minneapolis that
then spawned uh kind of CopyCat protests
and riots or uprisings whatever you want
to call them and dozens of cities all
across the United States and the San
Francisco Bay area where I live there
were massive protests and riots in
Oakland and San Francisco but also Mass
looting and violence and many of the
suburbs and surrounding communities and
you know I had gone to several uh
protests and
riots and kind of witnessed and reported
and tweeted in this particular Community
this is just outside of Oakland
um
there had been kind of opportunistic
looting
um the police in this small community
outside of Oakland were deployed to the
bigger cities of San Francisco and
Oakland and end this moment where there
were no police uh people uh I don't know
if they're protesters I don't think we
know exactly who they were but they
looted the main shopping mall they
looted
um the auto dealership 80 cars were
stolen May the cars were like driven
into buildings and it was just mass
chaos I was trying to make sense of it I
was walking around with a friend of mine
interviewing different Community
residents and activists
uh and you know just I was asking the
same question to everyone do you have
anything you want to get off your chest
you know this was a moment for
expression
and as I was walking back to my car a
young man followed me and said hey are
you with the media I have something I
want to talk about and I was like okay
and I talked to him for a minute and he
was
you know just very interesting he wanted
to share his internal contradictions he
was a supporter of black lives matter
but he said that
two of his cousins were murdered in East
Oakland more impoverished working-class
part of Oakland
and they were not killed by police not
killed by a white person
and he had to wonder he said you know
uh no none of these people none of these
protesters there was no media no one
seemed to care about my family but it
doesn't change the tragedy just as
George Floyd's mother Grieves for him
his aunt Grieves for his two cousins but
the political Dynamic is completely
different why does his why do the the
lives of his cousins seem to matter less
um than others does it only matter with
a racial contrast if it's a white person
if it's a politicized context like a a
police officer taking the life doesn't
matter
you know out of speaking to people all
day at the protests you know I thought
his remarks were the most interesting
he's made it very clear that he was a
supporter of black lives matter he
simply said he wanted it to be a more
broad beautiful movement that takes into
account all the different ways that
black lives are taken in the United
States why do you think that's such a
controversial why was that so
controversial for him to to say that
it's not controversial
outside of the media outside of Academia
outside of the the activist community in
this you know just a month later in
southeast Washington DC there was a
protest for more policing
um you know coming out of a senseless
murder of a child
um
and you know there are communities
ravished by violent crime by gang
violence uh and there's a robust demand
for
Public Safety for law enforcement for
Solutions uh for crime
but there's kind of a pathological sense
within certain subsets of the media of
of Academia on the activist class uh
that kind of view these issues through a
black and white lens that
police are descendants of slave catchers
you know that's where they kind of
originated from which is not true
um that police are the source of all
violence in in America that they're the
Vanguard of capitalism and if we just do
away with police if we abolish police if
we defund police you know all the
problems in America will evaporate
um it's it's kind of um it's an extreme
dogmatic view but it it and it's always
kind of percolated around the fringes of
media but in this moment of 2020 it
burst onto the mainstream it burst into
the corporate boardrooms and into
mainstream media Outlets
um it's so popular is that it would
burst into journalism journalist
responsibility is to support the news
and and I recall although I can't for
the top of my head remember who
published the article in defense of
looting and then there was the famous
um video report uh broadcast of someone
reporting with fires in the background
saying mostly peaceful protests so what
was going on within journalism like the
ignoring the rest of society why if
their responsibility is to Simply report
the news why was there sort of an
activist well I'm a slant to it I think
there's a very complicated long answer
to this but the succinct version is that
you know we've had a collapse in
ordinary journalism over 20 years the
advertising Revenue that funded most
newspapers and dailies
went to Google and Facebook so you know
where I'm from Washington DC and
Baltimore you had these big Regional
newspapers they had a Metro desk that
covered crime that covered everyday
lives of people they were all laid off
you know or mostly laid off because of
this loss of Revenue you have the only
journalism jobs available at these kind
of clickbaity online Outlets it's now
not seen as a you know journalism used
to be a working class middle class job
with a very diverse kind of background
going into it now it's an elite Prestige
job if you you're more likely to see
people who came from a very privileged
background who are really not connected
to the lives of normal Americans you
know it the only way you can really
afford being a journalist I've been very
lucky but for many people uh going into
journalism they kind of had to rely on
their parents or some other kind of
cushion of wealth to afford these very
low paid jobs
um and so you've had this kind of
bifurcated media where uh people where
journalism used to have a a very varied
socio-economically diverse background
now it's really just the the top
echelons of societies
echelons then not taking that whoever it
is why wouldn't they take the
responsibility uh seriously to report
the news rather than to report you know
in in a kind of by a completely biased
way I mean there's always bias they view
a lot of these debates around violence
around politics around inequality around
American society
through an abstract
lens I suppose
um a lot of them haven't talked to
people who are most affected by violence
in society you know we in the United
States it depends on the year but it
kind of ranges between something like 16
000 to 18 000 homicides per year um
most of these are not connected to what
you see in the news I mean journalists
know what gets clicks are school
shootings and police shootings but this
is a tiny tiny you know percent of a
percent
um uh number of the homicides in America
most of them come from you know domestic
disputes gangs
um cycles of of violence and very
impoverished communities and there's
really no political angle to them I mean
this is what happens every night in
America I don't know when this will
broadcast but just kind of look at the
major news media in St Louis or
Cleveland or Chicago and you know why
people are getting killed in America
it's not you know
um political extremists or cops or
whomever most of the K there's these
cases it's just regular people kind of
enacting these cycles of violence but
for the journalists who occupy very
powerful positions in National media and
left-wing media uh these stories are too
morally complex they want the simplistic
one-dimensional Story of Evil racist
cops and killing people
um
there's also just coming out of the the
Trump the tail end of the Trump
Administration
um this huge demand for kind of activist
media that uh is going to have you know
you're going to have the story that
finally takes down the Trump
Administration that you know takes down
one of his policies so there's there had
been kind of a build up of
um
kind of uh political style reporting uh
all going into 2020 and for you know I
think for for the average person they
were being misinformed in a lot of these
debates I mean this is when they were
being told about what's you know there's
been there there was a gigantic demand
suddenly for uh journalism that
represented the African-American
Community for people of color
um
reporting about police violence and and
violence in general uh but for a lot of
these reporters they didn't talk to
normal working class middle class
African-Americans polls consistently
showed even in
um the the immediate aftermath of the
George Floyd killing that something like
70 or 80 percent of African Americans in
this country in the United States uh
want current levels or higher levels of
policing that's consistent among polls
um you know no one wants police
brutality and people support reform but
this idea of abolishing the police
um defunding the police it came from an
extreme Elite in America and then it
kind of filtered down through the median
activist class it never represented the
actual opinions of normal Americans uh
and I think that's what really
conflicted people and that led to the uh
backlash against this very ordinary
interview that I conducted it conflicted
with this activist image it punctured
this image
and it angered a lot of people I you
know after I posted this video I trended
nationally for a day and a half almost
two days as a racist I had colleagues
who accused me of being racist for
posting this interview
um you know I had people threatening to
punch me to protest outside of my home
you know I just it was just a flood of
hate
um and at the kind of height of racial
anger in America uh it felt like the
walls were kind of closing in because
you know it's like this was a unique
moment in history and and four or two
days later you issued an apology
yeah you know to be honest with you and
this is a little bit uncomfortable to
talk about but I I couldn't sleep those
two days you know I'm just looking at my
phone seeing the emails
ping every few seconds with eight
messages with death threats with you
know people calling you a racist which
in many ways is much worse than a death
threat because you know people online
will make empty threats but being
vilified as a racist is
um makes you unemployable in kind of any
intellectual job
um you can't really work anywhere if
you're seen as a racist so you know I
was horrified and it's also like this
kind of internal
um contortions that I was engaging in
because I was like you know I've kind of
dedicated my life to reporting on issues
around organized bigotry and
discrimination and here I am now
vilified as the country's top racist you
know at least for that moment in time um
it was very painful and
yeah and then also the lack of
solidarity you know I've been I think a
team player at The Intercept I was there
since the relaunch in 2015.
um I've helped Mentor my colleagues help
them with stories I'm very supportive of
them and their journalism and then for
to see uh half or not more than half of
them engage in this kind of public mob
accusing me of racism almost all of them
without ever talking to me once just
kind of seeing me Trend as a racist and
then agreeing that I'm a racist and and
retweeting and promoting these attacks
it was like wow I mean
when you're part of an organization any
institution but you know a medium small
size journalism Outlets very intimate
you know we're all working together on a
daily basis tries to hear that because
of of Glenn Greenwood's history he's
he's someone who who I consider has
great integrity and so yeah and Glenn
was now part of the public utilization
absolutely not no he you know um you
know privately very supportive of me and
there were quite a few reporters and
editors who were privately very
supportive but publicly
um they came out publicly no but
publicly many of the other reporters and
copy editors and some of the editors
were condemning me it's so astonishing
because if you look you're not even
speaking you're just asking a guy
questions yeah my question was do you
have anything you want to get off your
chest yeah and so that's enough to be
deemed racist
um uh so when you publish the apology it
sort of sounds like you're under
tremendous stress and duress
yeah I mean I'd kind of received a
message from the editorial leadership
that I had violated certain guidelines
and I was under other pressure to
apologize and you know I felt like it
was the right thing to do to salvage my
career at the moment uh so I did post
this fairly long apology where I I you
know I apologized for
um any
insensitivity uh during this moment but
also kind of backed up my my belief that
you know
um you can't have Criminal Justice
Reform without
um hand-in-hand reducing violence in
society otherwise you're going to lead
to backlash or that acknowledging that
um African Americans do face
disproportionate level of certain forms
of uh police discrimination especially
non-lethal policing I think that the
evidence is very clear that African
Americans receive a higher degree of
traffic stops
um than other racial groups you know I
have your your viewers can read my whole
apology it's still online I think it's
most like uh striking about it is that
you're apologing for how your reporting
made others feel in fact whose feelings
are harmed
yeah do you think journalists need to be
sensitive about
the truth in how they present it no but
they do need to be sensitive in the way
they communicate every the reason you
are reporter is that you choose your
Awards carefully and you pick content
you create contacts for every fact you
present
um so a certain level of sensitivity is
important but
um you know I do
regret certain aspects or maybe even the
entire apology I'm still kind of working
for this
um personally
um because
you know I've I've written probably over
2 000 stories in the last 15 years as a
journalist I'm less proud of a few maybe
I should apologize for the few pieces
that I'm less proud of I didn't I don't
think actually my interview with Max
uh quite deserves an apology I I didn't
actually harm anyone with that interview
so if I mean if anything it's you
broadening the the conversation no and
Max actually you know the young man that
I interviewed he looked me up after
seeing my cancellation happen and
um rapid motion and he called me and he
said this is this is crazy I think
you're being bullied because of your
race
um you know do you think he's right
about that do you think you're voted for
your race you know In This Moment he's
he he made the point to me that if you
were African-American this wouldn't have
happened this is happening because
you're not and I think he's probably
right about that there was kind of a
racial Dynamic to it
um although you're not a white CIS male
sure but like you know in the politics
of race
um
especially Asian Americans that kind of
lose their POC card the second they say
something that's perceived as
conservative or moderate um
doesn't ever I think even black people
do sure exactly um it's very cute for
Asian Americans but it absolutely
applies to any minority
um so look earlier in this conversation
you said that there's a the elite
echelons of American society are going
into into journalism and I noticed
through that period that liberal media
was not talking uh firstly some of these
other Dynamics to the to the race
relations in America but also when it
came to antifa and far left extremism
you had that they were almost completely
ignoring it
and um
yet you work were covering it
why were you the only one from the left
covering it
well broadly speaking I'm interested in
violence and Society I mean just to have
a civilization to have a society
I believe and this is perhaps my bias we
can't engage in political debate with a
violent you know dynamic um that's how
violence unravels in society once we
kind of destroy our Norms around public
discourse
um we see violence ratchet up and we
can't really solve any big public policy
or political phenomenon if one side or
both sides start resort resorting to
violence it's very danger for societies
to look around the world and where
violence is unraveled leads to some very
bad things so you know I've written
about right-wing violence uh for a very
long time and you know just as in terms
of my my principles around non-violence
I apply this to the far left as well you
know back in 2017 after Trump's election
we saw this explosion in political
violence on both left and right groups
although the tendency was usually
left-wing groups going into these Street
battles and fighting each other that's
by the way a point of contention I think
there's a long debate about who's worse
even if some people accept that there's
left-wing violence they'll say but
they're right-wing violence is much
worse are you suggesting that actually
the tendency was that the violence came
more from the left than from the right
absolutely and this is also hosts
Charlottesville era yeah and even the
Charlotte's real thing is interesting
you know um
I mean actually in full disclosure I
mean I I grew up kind of in the punk
music scene in the Washington DC area
going to you know anti-war protests at
the outside of the Iraq War and War on
Terror you know living near DC there's
always a protest to go to and I was kind
of part of a punk kind of you know
organization that was essentially the
same as antifa same style whatever and
you know what were they cool anti-racist
action
um I don't know if they're still around
this is a long time ago this is when I
was an adolescent and
um at the time
uh I think in I believe and
I think it was 2002 uh there was a large
protest of white supremacists who came
to Washington DC to kind of March around
and wave flags and be provocative
you know just a few years ago I went
back and looked at the news clips and
this is in another era of the United
States you know not that long ago there
was kind of a norm that when neo-nazis
or the clan came to protest there was
more or less a media blackout like these
people are here to just
to agitate to gain attention ignore them
so let's ignore them take the oxygen
away from them
um and that was generally the case for
this uh protest this Neo-Nazi protest in
DC and you know I was uh you know very
young and uh went with some friends and
you know people went and threw rocks and
tried to fight them and you know did the
kind of antifa thing and it was
exhilarating as a I don't know 13 14
year old but
um I I wasn't very politically developed
at the time not very mature and what's
interesting here is that
tiny group of antifa tiny group of
neonatus but still like maybe 600 I
think that's that's what the official
tally was at the time but no major major
media coverage no one's seriously harmed
they came to DC they left they dispersed
nothing happened when Charlottesville
happened it was essentially the same
number of people 600 Nazis coming for
attention coming to provoke people but
instead of it being a media blackout
instead of just a small protest
contingent that came in you know rabble
roused and left you had hundreds if not
thousands of counter protesters you had
hundreds of reporters you had this like
gigantic spectacle that then became much
more violent you know like this and for
the exact same problem 600 you're in the
country of 320 million million people
you're always going to have some kind of
extremist group
um you're never gonna rid yourself of of
a group of 600 you know extremists
the question is how to deal with them
and uh for the 2002 uh response of
basically ignoring them having a small
group of protesters and then that's it
versus the 2017's
um Charlottesville massive response did
that really help anyone did that did it
actually tone down the violence or did
it increase the level of violence you
know so many brawls on the street uh
Heather heyer one of the left-wing
protesters killed
um you know many different kind of
clashes all around the country in
relation to this even where uh I live in
the San Francisco Bay Area there were
then
brawls on the street that were in
reaction to Charlottesville it just like
wants to kind of unspool violence in
society like we were talking about
earlier it's hard to put it back in the
there's a couple of inconsistencies here
about if I may because earlier say
you're interested in violence and
Reporting it yeah you you're not
suggesting that ignoring it is the
correct thing to do one as a journalist
should report it I think just place it
in context like if you look at the
um reporting around the 2002 event it's
like a couple it's it's it's a small
item in the Washington Post it's a small
item in the wash Washington examiner you
know some of the smaller newspapers it's
not this massive head I know in CNN it's
all day you know uh Fox News it's all
day MSNBC it's it's all mine covering
this news and you know the protesters
saying you know this is this is Hitler
on the March if we don't fight fight
them in the street the parking lot here
we gotta fight them at the grocery store
we've got to fight them in our community
it's just it's like let's just remember
we're we've always in the United States
we've always had a small group of
extremists of every type there are black
nationalists that are violent they're
white nationalists that are violent
they're you know the you know Nation of
Islam people that are that are extreme
do we need to go fight all these people
in the street and pretend that they are
on the verge of taking over this country
like I just I you gotta as a journalist
place it in context the other thing I
know quite followers you also said
there's more left-wing violence now
earlier but both examples you give of
2002 and 2017 were where there was it
was started by the neo-nazis so
is it always
it's that doesn't sort of suggest to me
that there are more left-wing or at
least they're working it certainly
fluctuates right like the Trump election
people lost their minds and thought that
political violence uh was the only
appropriate response I don't you know I
remember 2009 after the Obama election
there was not a lot of
um left-wing violence
um but the left reacted violently to
Trump in a lot of ways uh this didn't
exist not that long ago but it would be
I think uh wrong not to identify it you
know their antifa protests beating up
journalists uh attacking counter
protesters attacking even innocent
bystanders especially on the west coast
in cities like Portland Seattle San
Francisco
uh that were predominantly left wing you
know just to call a spade a spade
um but that's not to say that there
isn't right-wing violence I mean
certainly that that was that's been a
one of the things that I see right wing
is saying is that when there are
neo-nazis together that it's actually
fed
dressed up do you think that they're
wrong about that do you think that
there's uh that there are the the right
wing don't take seriously enough far
right extremism
I mean I I was and we were talking about
my mega cancellation I got many canceled
in 2017 for making this point look at
the history of the FBI
um they go into political organizations
on both the left and the right and they
agitate and they encourage violence and
they entrap people uh and arrest them
um yes the proud boys have FBI
informants many of these alt-right and
conservative groups are filled with
police local police and FBI informants
and many of these antifa groups have FBI
informants and police informants you
know there's been quite a lot of
reporting that some of the Denver
chapters of antifa organizations that
were encouraging people to buy buy guns
to go out and engage in violence these
were cops that were dressed up in
handkerchiefs and whatnot you know um
and we've got like a very long uh
history of this kind of police agitation
and you know I just just pointing out to
the left to say hey look if you're if
you're if you're engaged in this kind of
far left activism although I'm not even
sure if that's the right term for it
just be aware that if someone's
encouraging you to engage in violence
maybe be a little bit skeptical yeah
that carried ends well into John 6 and
there's still a lot of spec regulation
and perhaps conspiracy about those sort
of infiltrations in John 6 did you cover
jansik you know what I I followed it
very closely I wrote very little
um I you know it's still one of the one
of the most fascinating moments in
American history for a lot of reasons
um in terms of just escalating speaking
of the FBI's Powers
um I think very scary
um a lot of kind of questions still
Linger on the role of uh potential role
of FBI informants we know many were in
the crowd or many were members of these
organizations that participated in
January 6.
uh apparently some of these uh security
videos are going to be disseminated by
the new Republican majority in the house
to be kind of more closely examined
a lot of questions remain so
since all of that you have you you cover
uh you you're invited as I said earlier
into Twitter HQ this is this is
forwarding uh 2000 so the 2020 end of
2022.
um I want to ask about your specific
reporting from there but before that
um what was that experience like as a
journalist was that an exciting thing to
walk into or did you feel like this was
a big story like about to happen or what
and did you meet Elon who you with
Michael and and Barry and Matt tell me
what happened well it's it's strange it
was weird it was it was exhilarating it
was exciting but also just weird I mean
I've you know I've reported on
I don't have never Quantified it but
probably dozens of leaked hacked and
other kind of you know documents that
were not intentionally released by
powerful corporations from billionaires
from governments all over the world I've
reported on documents allegedly hacked
by the Algerian government by the Qatari
government by the Russian government
documents leaked for major Banks from
defense contractors from surveillance
firms
um you know I've done these kind of uh
you know inside document stories so many
times in my career but I've never gone
to a source where the CEO actually
invites you in and says hey look at all
of our kind of most hidden secrets of
this very powerful uh company and please
publish them as as quickly as possible I
mean it's just
I mean it still kind of doesn't make
sense to me but I it was very exciting
so what you you were in did you have an
engineer with you going through the
computers and and there was never a kind
of um Regular process and I joined a
little bit after Tybee
um Barry Weiss and others had gotten
started on this and I only went in for
about four days but
yeah I went in and there was a lawyer
and an engineer who was kind of assigned
to help us we would kind of write
different queries for searching the
various tools and emails and databases
of Twitter and that lawyer would then
conduct those searches and then show us
the results so did you have an idea of
what you wanted to find how did you
start yeah you know I'm I was I've I
wrote a big feature piece before uh Elon
bought Twitter back in October 2022
about
social media censorship from the
Department of Homeland Security a lot of
the same emails but just I obtained them
a different way the Missouri attorney
general had sued the Department of
Homeland Security and through the
litigation process a lot of emails have
been produced I was also talking to a
whistleblower from the Department of
Homeland Security so I had already been
on this beat so I was interested in the
kind of big government censorship story
that taibi and shellenberger and others
were reporting but I went in there
hoping you know I'm like okay this story
on government censorship and attempts at
shaping the public conversation around
the 2020 election and covet and others
um it's they're kind of already
dominating that that side of the of the
story I wanted to do something different
in terms of my own style as a journalist
I always have like
you know 15 stories half finished and
then I just need to push to get them
done and yeah I had started a story
actually earlier that year about uh the
Pentagon the Department of Defense
had worked with various contractors and
social media companies to do exactly
what
um you know we've alleged that Russia
and Iran and China do to the US which is
create fake identities on social media
to manipulate the domestic political
debate those countries or in America
what those countries do to America we do
back to them sure and that and that
piece has never really been fully
explored and reported
um there had been a report that kind of
um identified some aspects of this I
through a source found a contractor here
who worked for the military uh for this
project in the past I conducted an
interview with them I'd gathered a
little bit of evidence but I just didn't
get that story over the finish line and
here I am in Twitter headquarters
where I'm wondering okay if the Pentagon
is working with Twitter and Facebook to
create fake identities to manipulate uh
the debate around Iran and
um in in areas where the the Pentagon
has kind of a focus
hopefully there's something there and I
found more than I could have imagined
um just looking at the Twitter emails I
found that back in 2017 you know that
the Pentagon had this network of fake
identities
um in Yemen in Syria in Iraq Arab
language accounts that they took covert
that they removed any kind of
identification with the Pentagon they
gave them new names and new kind of
monikers that they're just you know a
regular person living by the Euphrates
or something and uh they asked Twitter
secretly
um we brought this network of propaganda
accounts
uh
can you help us boost them and so you
know back in the day when you received a
verified blue check if it gave you a a
variety of benefits you couldn't be
blacklisted you were more likely to
Trend
um uh you're more just more visible on
the timeline
the Twitter engineered a special
verification check mark for the
pentagon's Arab language propaganda
accounts but without the blue check so
it was an invisible blue check that
conferred the same benefits
um they later classified this whole
project but worked with Twitter worked
with Facebook and then created fake news
portals basically to you know project
the pentagon's message on you know the
war in Yemen uh the war in Syria uh
promoting uh you know stories that were
damaging to U.S adversaries like Iran
like there's a story that they promoted
using these accounts claiming that Iran
was taking Afghan refugees and
harvesting their organs you know these
kind of salacious stories that uh you
know are used to basically destabilize
and harm our U.S adversaries in the
region
um and it's just fascinating to me
because as Twitter was providing this
white glove uh Service uh to the
Pentagon and their propaganda their
secret propaganda accounts
Twitter was going to Congress going to
the American Media and saying we are
absolutely against any state-backed
information operation any propaganda
effort we will identify any
government-funded propaganda effort we
will shut it down and we will disclose
it on our website all the while they
were assisting the U.S military with
their own state-backed propaganda effort
inconsistent as a being it's not that
surprising to me that the America would
have disinformation is used as a means
as a way to fight International Wars
what's what was more shocking from the
Twitter files generally is that that was
being used against the American people
or rather there was that there was an
interplay between big Tech and
intelligent services and big government
to censor and propagate disinformation
on the American people themselves well
you know there's there's been
long-standing law that's now been kind
of chiseled away in the U.S that the CIA
the military can engage in various you
know underhanded propaganda overseas but
there's a red line in terms of
influencing U.S audiences the internet
destroys that red line you know anything
that we do overseas to shape you know
various conflicts and adversaries
Americans can see that as well so any of
these kind of post-war restrictions on
American propaganda
basically don't exist and yeah I mean
just in terms of these other broader
debates I mean I was fascinated looking
at the Twitter files I knew that there
had been kind of an embedded special FBI
team that was you know communicating
regularly with with Twitter shaping some
of their contact decisions kind of
nudging them towards censorship of
various accounts I just didn't
understand the volume I mean I'm looking
at these emails of major Twitter
Executives they're getting emails almost
every other day from FBI and Department
of Homeland Security officials I mean I
just I can't imagine being at a major
Media company or social media company
with that level of pressure from the
National Security State I mean that just
I mean regardless of the actual details
of of each request that level of
persistence and constant pressure
um that was that took me aback so as
well as the style story uh you also did
a piece about how the pharmaceutical
industry lobbied social media to shape
content around vaccine policy yeah
that's right
um there was a huge demand to shape
covid discourse
um I think for everyone in the public
and media and the public there's a
question of the black box where are
these decisions coming from we could see
that these you know stories questioning
the lab leak Theory uh questioning
lockdowns seemed to not ever trend on
Twitter or you know on Facebook they
would get deleted
um there was click it was clearly there
was clearly a lot of censorship looking
from the outside but to actually look
from the inside we got a better picture
um
one of the organizations that was
instructing Twitter on which accounts uh
to censor on various uh coveted content
stories including criticism of lockdowns
including questions around the vaccine
efficacy
um
uh came from this organization uh public
good uh projects uh this was an
organization that was fully funded by
the vaccine makers the biotech
Innovation organization that's the lobby
group that represents moderna and Pfizer
they provided a special Grant to these
disinformation researchers they
organized organized this this project
and they had backdoor access telling
Twitter they would send a weekly update
of which Twitter accounts should be
censored which of them should be Shadow
banned including some very major
accounts like Zero Hedge so big Pharma
were telling social media to censor
specific people about the vaccine that's
right and
um they just used a third-party conduit
completely funded by big Pharma through
public good projects yes
um funneling the money to them and then
their their workers their employees
would send a list every week to to
Twitter saying here's what you should
censor wow and and only uh last week
shellenberger and TYB released the the
um report that they have evidence that
patients zero were indeed from the Wuhan
lab funded by fauci uh and they were
doing gain of function research in and
all of these stories they were people
who even suggested it were told that
they were conspiracy theorists and
um those stories were were shut down
it's uh that censorship through covert
has been absolutely astonishing yeah I
mean this is what kind of annihilates I
think a lot of The credibility of the
disinformation industry as it were and
uh for a lot of media outlets and social
media platforms that perhaps the biggest
story of the century so far
um or at least the last 10 years uh was
I mean it's looking more and more likely
that kova did come from a lab but you
were branded as a conspiracy theorist or
a racist for reporting the truth one of
your other stories on censorship is
actually a story about your former
employer Pierre omigio uh so you uh this
month published an article uh arguing or
or reporting that
um he financed the the public private
partnership to censor election related
Twitter and Facebook
post what can you tell me about that
story well you know I've been doing
these ongoing stories about the kind of
bureaucracy around censorship how does
it actually work what are they going
after and what's the role of the Federal
Government I'm just I'm super interested
in how the Department of Homeland
Security has kind of had Mission creep
it was created to stop another 911 and
now they're somehow involved in telling
Twitter and Facebook what to do or
nudging them on which pieces of content
to take down I mean this this incredible
growth of the bureaucracy is fascinating
to me and it raises constitutional
issues it raises basic fairness issues
and and civil liberties questions but
also just looking at how this works and
I've been filing um record requests with
some of the academics who have been
advising the government on these
censorship efforts and I got some of the
records back and one of the records is a
report from a contractor uh Center for
Internet Security that set up this
misinformation reporting portal and this
is the
the kind of infrastructure used by
various ngos the Democratic party and
others to report you know examples of
alleged misinformation uh to the
government and the government would
forward them on
um to Twitter or Facebook
this kind of reporting portal though you
know that this kind of censorship issue
it raises two issues one is this even
constitutional should the government
have any role but I think if you kind of
made a clear note
let's let's take let's take it let's
let's for the sake of argument and I'm
sympathetic that it's a clear no but
let's say for the sake of argument that
perhaps the misinformation reporting
world uh can make a constitutional case
that the government should be involved I
think the clear second question after
that if you take them at their word is
is it being done fairly are are the
various stakeholders in society and if
you're engaging in a misreporting
misinformation reporting around election
are both political parties being
represented or all the political parties
being represented because in the most
delicate time for any type of
um you know public discourse is right
before an election I think we can all
agree on that
and I think the clear question to the
second question there's a clear answer
to the second question is no because
what I found in this story is that even
the infrastructure
that was created to censor tweets around
the 2020 election was funded by one of
the largest
Joe Biden donors in the country and
that's Pierre midiar he donated donated
45 million dollars to various
organizations that helped elect Joe
Biden while partnering uh and and fully
funding uh this organization that helped
take down mostly conservative tweets
um and so and so if I wasn't clear he's
the the financial backer of The
Intercept yeah your former Media company
that you left this year but also and I
think this is
in understanding the uh what is being
called the censorship industrial complex
the web the complex web that it is is
that it's also coming it's a it's the
public private interplay it's not just
these institutions it's not just the
media as we've discussed it's not just
intelligence and government and social
media but there's uh the private sphere
as well are acting uh into there's an
interplay between all of them and it's
probably generally quite popular amongst
about half the population
yeah and it's become just such a
a partisan issue it's suddenly popular
with many Democrats
um even though Free Speech has
traditionally been associated with the
left um that has flipped but you know
that's right even with Pierre midiar I
think a lot of what he's funded as a
philanthropist
um is generally laudable you know he
works on
um many different issues and you know I
don't want to uh criticize everything
he's done but in this particular case it
just seems strange to me because when he
founded when he helped found the
intercept he you know endowed it with a
certain amount of money
um he did it under an umbrella company
called first look uh media and under
that first look first look and First
Look was
um a kind of link to the First Amendment
because he said he he's so concerned
with free speech and a free Society
where the you know he was inspired by
the Edward Snowden uh you know leaks or
disclosure of you know Mass surveillance
of Americans that you know the
government is where was working and
still working with the phone companies
that the uh various internet companies
to collect basically every interaction
at least the metadata and in addition to
other interactions and he was appalled
at that and that was part of the reason
that he funded The Intercept here we are
um nine years later after those or 10
years later after those disclosures he's
now funding
uh you know non-profits and contractors
that work with the government that
engage in censorship do you think he
sees the irony in that
that's a good question I mean if I had a
moment with him that'd be my first topic
to discuss as it would be mine uh so you
mentioned um the that from 9 11 that so
some of this started with the
surveillance from 9 11 and how that
slowly
um morphed into what what this is and
and
um I I'm quite curious about that as
well but snowden's relevant from there
from 9 11 you get Stellar Wind where
it's the surveillance is then they're
surveilling the American people and I
discussed this with shellenberger uh
Hamilton 68 group The the Russian hoax
rather the Russian disinformation is a
reason then to start that justified
censorship from media today or pre-mask
Twitter and and but other still other
social media I'm quite interested by
that story particularly as you also
reported on
Flashpoint which is was originally
formed to focus on infiltrating Islamic
Terror groups and that group has now
been has now morphed
um to surveil vaccine manage so if I
understood that correctly yeah that's
right so what's the what what was that
specific story yeah this is a you know I
think there are many examples that show
um
the growth of the homeland security
surveillance State and this private
contractor is kind of the perfect one
because it arranges the whole gamut of
of of every American who should be
concerned with civil liberties and and
the kind of invasion here this is a firm
uh founded by someone named Evan Coleman
who um you know he worked with various
organizations that were infiltrating
mosque and Islamic communities after 9
11 gathering information eventually
founded Flashpoint as a company that
went into you know Al Qaeda message
boards and others they gathered all this
Intel on um Muslim Americans and and
Muslim extremist groups and they would
and he would sell it back to the FBI
sell it back uh to the Department of
Defense
um as this firm grew but the war on
terror wound down he pivoted this is a
company that now is very large they just
kind of acquired another surveillance
contractor last year and you know I I've
interviewed some of the officials there
pieced together kind of the the public
history and this is a company that now
it still works for the FBI
um it also works for large American
corporations and what they do now is
they create fake identities online they
infiltrate
private online communities whether
that's on Reddit or a Discord or on
WhatsApp and others and they take this
intelligence and they sell it back to
their various public and private clients
and and for a company that started out
surveilling and spying on Muslims now
they're spying on groups that are even
considered
um conservative that are maybe perhaps
more right-leaning the anti-vaccine yeah
so so one of the the you know in in the
United States we had this big debate
around the vaccine mandate early in 2021
as the vaccines were being rolled out
various large corporations were
requiring their employees to receive the
vaccine or otherwise they would be
dismissed and then the federal
government enacted a very controversial
policy
um through uh through OSHA saying that
if you have a hundred employees or more
um you have to be tested weekly or
receive the vaccine or you you must be
dismissed from your job
this policy led to thousands of people
all across the country losing their job
their their similar mandate from
different
um cities and states uh eventually found
unconstitutional except for one carve
out for health care workers but at the
time many of the
leading activists against the Mandate
were people who worked in the
transportation industry truckers people
worked in the airline industry I mean
especially the airline workers they were
on the front lines they were the most
essential workers many of these
employees were the among the first to be
infected with covid-19 and recover and
these mandates had no exception for
natural immunity from prior affection
um so not so you know I think very
reasonably they argued that these
mandates should not apply to us so you
know if we've already been infected by
covid-19 why are we being forced to take
this shot
um it's essentially a labor issue which
you know it was once seen as a left-wing
issue if if Working Class People of
people who are demanding more rights on
the job from government and corporate
interference
um there should be some sympathy from
the left they didn't receive received it
for most left-wing groups but the the
added kind of insult to injury here is
the they were being actively surveilled
Flashpoint infiltrated their private
chat groups
um where uh spying on on what they're
doing in terms of their organizing you
know they had regular weekly webinars
they had actions you know like any
activist groups
um and you had this uh very
sophisticated uh government-backed uh
surveillance firm Gathering their their
information their private information
wow
um do you do you think that this stuff
you know your your story what happened
in June 2020 at the height of the racial
tension in America and this stuff of the
vaccines are we was it just a a do did
America go mad and are we kind of out of
that now that we're post covered you
think or was it was it a time of lunacy
and uh or do you think we can expect
this to continue do you think
where do you see this stuff going
I don't know I feel like there's um a
general
uh unease in America it's not as extreme
that was kind of that's perhaps the the
height of uh extreme
public policy and politics I don't think
we're going to enter that same period of
riots uh anytime soon uh the level of
racial anger uh the kind of
semi-authoritarian uh you know
squelching of speech and lockdowns
around biosecurity measures
but I don't know I mean I don't think
anyone predicted 2020. I might I might
on some my own question there a little
bit another story is that you you
reported on Ukrainian intelligence
contacting FBI uh to censor American
journalists which suggested okay so we
had various relations then we had covert
and now Ukraine is is the same
infrastructure at play to Center America
continued yeah I think okay that
actually is a perfect
wind up to the way I'm thinking about
this now I don't see the level of
phenomenon again but hard to predict the
future but it it created the
bureaucratic and legal and political
precedent
uh for the infrastructure for more
potential censorship for you know more
kind of government and corporate control
of our daily lives for shaping the
discourse
um January 6 actually Keys into this I
mean to see the FBI working with almost
every uh big internet company a big app
company to track down Americans for
simple trespass if we see another kind
of left wing or right-wing political
phenomenon in the future now the FBI has
a new suite of tools in their toolbook
to track down Americans
um I think a lot of these you know if we
didn't have the
kind of Hysteria around Russia in 2017
which created the foreign influence task
force with the FBI which then created
this new relationship with Twitter and
Facebook which then became this
censorship apparatus or you know
whatever you want to call it
misinformation reporting apparatus
around the 2020 election in kovid
you know all these things leads one
leads to the other and now that you have
this FBI relationship with the social
media companies
you uh the war in Ukraine just Taps into
that so you have Ukrainian intelligence
officials they back in 2015 2012 they
didn't have this government apparatus
that they could just quickly key into
them now that this apparatus exists
um because of this various phenomenon
there's a an easy kind of TurnKey way
for intelligence agencies and other War
planners to shape the public discourse
around the conflict in Ukraine so for
future Wars for future elections future
issues this infrastructure exists and it
can be exploited so you're in London now
because shellenberg are here and they're
in event with Russell Brand about this
censorship issue
they or certainly Shannon Burger sees us
as a bit of a fight back and and
obviously reporting on it is step one of
the fight back do you think that this
can be dealt with or changed do you
hopeful do you think that shellenberg is
right to even bother trying do you think
do you think there can be a change to
this surveillance in this censorship
well I'm
you know I want to be optimistic and
look at public pools you know I've
written about FBI abuse of anti-war
protesters of Muslim Americans of other
kind of maybe viewed as left-wing issues
for my entire career and you know it
unfortunately it was partisan back then
you had Democrats concerned with the
Department of Homeland Security and the
FBI and Republicans kind of shrugging
their shoulders
today we see a Republican party and
conservative and moderate and even
independent Americans extremely upset at
the FBI and the Department of Homeland
Security and its wave and its role in
shaping the public discourse you have
presidential candidates
um you know promising reform you have
Congressional Republicans doing better
oversight hearings
um on these kind of unaccountable law
enforcement national security agencies
that I've ever seen in my you know in my
reporting career so we're seeing
momentum uh towards accountability
um and that makes me hopeful you know I
I think a lot of these these big
intractable issues the only way you get
movement is if you can find some
compromise between the left and the
right so you have
um an embolden FTC you have a small
number of journalists and activists on
the left that are so concerned with
these issues and you have um for the
very first time a conservative movement
a Republican party uh that would like to
see action I I I hope that there can be
some coming together uh for reform
great well at least uh fascinating
speaking to you where can listeners and
viewers find your work hi
www.leafong.com on Twitter LH f-a-n-g uh
yeah I'm I've been solo on substack for
about two months and really enjoying it
so I really appreciate the interview
that's great it's been fascinating
lifang thank you for speaking
[Music]
thank you